for more than 50 years fun Junk's family
has sold homewares in the markets of
mongkok the store once belonged to his
grandfather now he says they have no
choice but to close down for good
in this past year we haven't been able
to meet our minimum sales targets to pay
for salaries and rent we can't sustain
our business anymore so we must shut
down soaring costs of living and the
economic impacts of stringent covid-19
measures are taking a toll on many more
than 200 000 people have left the
territory in recent years that followed
beijing's imposition of a national
security law and Crackdown on descent in
2020 described by Amnesty International
as decimating that territory's freedoms
the city has now entered a technical
recession a top priority for the chief
executive is to boost the economy by
bolstering its dwindling Workforce Hong
Kong is one of the most competitive
economies in the world it also serves as
an important Gateway connecting mainland
China with Global Market we must be more
proactive and aggressive in competing
for Enterprises and competing for
talents Lee announced new Visa schemes
for top university graduates and perks
for foreigners who purchase property
analysts say Reviving Hong Kong's
reputation will take time this requires
political capacity it requires trust it
requires accountability and accountable
government we don't really have that at
the moment the government's got to earn
this some cued to receive a copy of
Lee's Maiden address in a speech lasting
three hours chief executive John Lee
spelled out his vision for a safe and
prosperous Hong Kong now many are
wondering how those ideas will shape
their lives Lee also raised the
importance of National Security and how
strengthening connections with the
mainland is an advantage for the
territory probing politicians say the
policies are exactly what the city needs
I I agree every Pawn every Pawn which
it's on the opponent of that we totally
agree the problem is how to implement
them in the coming of future
for many the hardship of recent years
has taken its toll
I find it quite difficult to live in
Hong Kong now as the economy is so bad I
don't have any expectations regarding
John Lee as the territory's leadership
promoted their attempts at Rejuvenation
it will have to contend with the
population that's skeptical about what
can actually be achieved Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Hong Kong